in übermächtigen schatten von corona
macht auch der klimawandel leider keine
nennenswerte pause
wie läuft es also bei der energiewende
geht so unser energie wendler also
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
arbeitet an einer reform des erneuerbare
energien gesetzes eeg kommt wohl im
januar kann ich mal kurz einen
zwischenstand haben wo er recht hat
leider bedeutet seine eg reform noch
mehr bürokratie wird man für viele
photovoltaik pioniere darunter
hausbesitzer die sich damals solarzellen
aufs dach genagelt haben läuft jetzt die
förderung aus und neue vorschriften
zwingen sie teuer nachzurüsten hier habe
ich zunächst mal zwei richtungs zelle
der muster rein diese beiden kommen raus
die zwei zähle auch funktioniert aber es
ist halt vorschrift soll räumt wegen der
neuen zähler braucht blasen laut
vorschrift auch noch einen neuen zähler
schrank so ausschaut kann ich dann
eigentlich die anlage still legen
abbauen
sie wird dann kein geld mehr für ihn
sondern ist sie kostet dann nur noch
gilt das gegenteil von anreiz die schade
und zusätzlich zum neuen zähler dem
smart meter holt man sich am besten
gleich noch einen steuerberater ins haus
und einen anwalt und einen sales manager
denn während der solarstrom früher
automatisch ins netz eingespeist wurde
muss man den bald selber an die anbieter
verschicken wie so ein vertreter
warum zahlen viele auf selbst erzeugten
und verbrauchten strom überhaupt eeg
umlage
sinnvoll ist das definitiv nicht macht
das in anderen bereichen auch nicht gibt
ja auch keine apfel steuer für den
apfelbaum im eigenen garten nicht so
laut der altmaier herthas tafel steuer
bisschen vorsichtig übrigens in den
niederlanden gibt es dank deutlich
weniger bürokratie fünfmal mehr
hausbesitzer mit solarpanel auf dem dach
okay vergessen wir mal so lang wie läuft
es bei der windenergie dachte ich mir es
werden kaum noch neue windräder gebaut
und vielen windparks droht das aus wegen
wegfall der eeg-förderung und
verschärfter abstandsregel das gilt
sogar für windräder die schon stehen
sobald man da weiß er nicht auch nur ein
generator austauscht
muss man das teil wieder neu genehmigen
lassen manche behörden werden sogar
extrem kreativ wenn es darum geht
anlagen zu verhindern
beispiel schwielowsee bei berlin die
gemeinde stimmt geschlossen für den bau
eines windrades neben einer
autobahnraststätte klingt okay denkt der
laie aber laut zuständigem
landesbetriebs straßenwesen
beeinträchtigen die geräusche der
windkraftanlage die erholungsfunktion
der rastanlagen und infolgedessen die
verkehrssicherheit auf der autobahn
nicht lachen
ich brauche meinen jahresurlaub
regelmäßig an der raststätte remscheid
die a1 im sommer absoluter traum hier
jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop
die windräder von catan das spiel zur
energiewende versuche irgendwo in
deutschland ein neues windrad zu bauen
da natürlich nicht viel zu nah am
wenigsten siedlung super andere stelle
da auch nicht mindestabstand zum
nächsten haus ist zehnmal die höhe des
windrads nein bist du bescheuert in dem
ort gibt es eine anti windkraft
bürgerinitiative und so geht das über
stunden bist du endlich keinen bock mehr
ist und auf gibst dann bot ein gegner
das neue kohlekraftwerk datteln 4 und
hat das spiel gewonnen
die windräder von göttern aus steuer und
macht nur spaß genau wie die
energiewende
wir hatten fest kein herz für wind und
sonne dann müssen eben autos unser klima
retten
beim soundsovielten auto gipfel im
kanzleramt gab es gerade noch mal drei
frische milliarden für die autoindustrie
wegen corona ja den zusammenhang
verstehe ich auch nicht aber die geste
zählt immerhin soll ein teil dieser
finanzspritze in noch mehr kaufprämien
für e autos fließen elektroautos hatten
bei den neuzulassungen im oktober 2020
schon 8,4 prozent marktanteil weiteren
9,1 prozent waren sogenannte plug in
hybride also rollende mogelpackung wenn
die batterie alle ist meist so nach drei
metern über spitz gerechnet sind das
ganz normale verbrenner nur halt viel
schwerer
im ganzen letzten jahr wurden 45.000 von
denen verkauft in diesem krisenjahr
schon über 130000 wow wir schauen mal
live zu albrecht humboldt
geschäftsführer von um bse hammergeil
hybrid humboldt warum sind hybride so
populär
ganz einfach hybride sind das beste aus
zwei welten two in one im grunde
transgender autos wer sich dieses baby
erholt kriegt ne fette elektro
kaufprämie und hat trotzdem und jetzt
kommt ein richtiges auto aha autos sind
keine richtigen autos
[Gelächter]
allein der sound wie ein treppenlift
klar hier ist auch eine batterie drin
aber die reicht in der regel bis zum
ende der garagenausfahrt dann übernimmt
der verbrenner
das ist so nicht von der politik dass
die hersteller trotzdem mit komplett
erfundene zahlen werben dürfen
wir finden überall den gleichen trend
nämlich dass die plug in hybridfahrzeuge
deutlich mehr verbrauchen als das was
offiziell angegeben wird
die kenntnis von den verbrennungsmotor
ischen fahrzeugen da sind es etwa 40
prozent mehr im durchschnitt bei den
plug in hybrid fahrzeugen sind es 200
300 oder sogar 400 prozent
aber wenn sie so viel mehr sprit
verbrauchen dann tue ich doch kaum was
fürs klima nein das ist ja das geniale
trotzdem gefördert deswegen ist ja peter
altmaier bei uns jeden monat mitarbeiter
des monats seit jahren bis zu 6000 750
euro kaufprämie plus steuervorteil bei
firmenwagen vor allem große unternehmen
kaufen plugins wie blöde für ihre
mitarbeiter hier ein flottenmanager
diese kabel das ist das ladekabel
die haben wir oft genug völlig ungenutzt
wenn wir die fahrzeuge zurück nehmen die
batterie war völlig überflüssig
300 kilo gewicht hat das fahrzeug
unnötigerweise mit rumgefahren co2
ausstoß höher als bei jedem normalen
motor ökologischer unsinn was für ein
völlig überflüssiger geiler und sinn
wenn man damit durchkommt geht alles
hier für einen geringen aufpreis packen
wir in ihren diesel einfach 300 kilo
steine dann haben sie exakt den gleichen
rang wie ein plug-in klimaschutz kann so
einfach sein
oder hier das ist ein trabant zweitakter
das giftigste auto das je gebaut wurde
aber hier auf dem dach ist eine kleine
solarzelle und damit wird der
zigarettenanzünder betrieben her mit der
fahrer krone
das hat doch mit elektromobilität gar
nichts mehr zu tun
es stimmt doch gar nicht ich habe hier
sogar eine ladesäule steuerlich voll
gefordert und die nutze ich auch und
zwar für unsere fast klimaneutrale
weihnachtsbeleuchtung halle
ja jesus hätte hybrid gekauft bestimmt
albrecht humboldt vielen dank
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
hallo hast du scheiße fährt haye